here is a breath of hilarity really one
of our favorite stories of all time
Tanzanian fashion designer based in
Houston called ASA koshman says she lost
her luggage the baggage claim of DCA
Washington Reagan National back in 2018.
a couple of days ago she was watching
Fox News and she saw the coverage of Sam
Brinton that would be Joe Biden's
non-binary nuclear waste disposal expert
who had this weird fetish involving
stealing women's clothes from airport
carousels and then it hit Thompson Sam
Britton was photographed wearing her
clothes and their very distinctive
clothes you're seeing the side by side
in your screen right now now we are in
touch with her she's in Tanzania right
now but when she gets back she promises
to come on this show and discuss what
it's like to have your fashion Creations
stolen by Joe Biden's nuclear waste
non-binary Airport fetishist
but in the meantime we're joined by
Chadwick Moore of The Spectator to
assess this ongoing story which really
is Chadwick you've got to admit the
greatest story ever now I just have to
ask you've been following this since the
beginning you first saw this guy Sam
Britton was your first thought I bet
this guy never steals women's underwear
off airport carousels
yeah you have to um pardon my glee
because I don't think anyone thought
this story could possibly get any better
and now you know two words that have to
apply to him that I would mean sincerely
in this case would be stunning and
really really Brave it's not like he's
parading around in a gap hoodie I mean
they're very distinctive you know quite
lovely clothing that he was wearing and
that poor designer having her Creations
defiled by the radioactive klepto Queen
in the energy Department I really feel
for her that must be awful but uh this I
I'm a little disappointed in myself and
and and in fellow journalists that none
of us took a closer look at his clothing
and asked what exactly he was wearing
because we should have been tipped off
the minute we saw some of these outfits
it looked like he raided a village in
Africa or something maybe would have
started getting more answers then
that was not off the rack and that
should have been the first tip-off that
he had a Tanzanian designer he was
stealing from
um and I agree with you we we fell down
on the job Chadwick Moore great to see
you tonight thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight